This week is Sourdough Week
and I'm gonna be sharing with you
some of my favourite sourdough recipes,
starting off with this simple sourdough bread.
I actually had a sourdough starter for years
before I actually made bread.
I'd use it for cooking and other things,
and I always was so daunted with bread.
But I finally started making this recipe
and it is the easiest sourdough bread recipe I found,
and it works every single time.
I've never had an issue with this recipe.
I don't know if it's the oven or the Dutch oven that I use,
but the bread always comes out with a nice soft crust.
It's not too hard. I've made some other recipes before
where the crust just came out really hard,
and my kids and my husband don't like that.
I'm gonna leave the recipe below.
But it's such a simple recipe.
It's flour, water,
sourdough starter and salt.
I start my bread in the evenings
and then I do my stretches and folds as the kids are taking a bath
and as we're winding down
ready to get ready for bed.
Once I'm done with my 3 to 4 stretch and fold,
sometimes I only get two in.
I'm gonna do a wet hand so my hands don't stick to the dough.
Once I'm done with my stretching folds,
I'll let it sit on the counter overnight
and then in the morning
I will shape the bread and put it into balancing Baskets,
or whatever basket or bowl that I have.
When I first started out, I didn't use fancy balancing baskets.
I just use little bowls.
And I even found some little baskets at the target,
like, $1 section at the front,
and I use those for a few years.
I always do my dough in batches of two loaves or four loaves.
So first I'm gonna cut the dough
into the amount of loaves I'm planning to make.
And then I'm gonna shape it.
I'm gonna first lay it out flat,
fold it in half, and roll it up,
up on itself. And then I'm gonna create tension on the top of the dough
by sliding and pulling the dough towards me.
My son does not having this part.
Then I'm gonna lightly dust the balance in baskets.
If I'm using a bowl,
I'd just put a tea towel in the basket instead of this cloth.
Once the loaves are in the baskets,
they're gonna rise for one more time.
You can either do this on the counter
if you wanna cook the bread over the next hour or two,
or you can put it this in the fridge.
And they will last in there for a few days.
So if you wanna put a pause on baking bread
and have them ready before dinner time at another date,
you can just pop them in the fridge.
I cover mine with the beeswax paper here.
Or you can use shower Caps,
plastic bags, anything to stop the dough from drying out.
I'm gonna leave the bacon instructions down with the recipe.
Happy baking